this morning the music world is
remembering grunge rock pioneer Chris
Cornell Cornell died unexpectedly late
last night he was in Detroit and he was
52 years old his music career spanned
more than three decades and he performed
with a number of bands this video is
believed to be from his final show last
night in Detroit just hours before his
death Anthony Mason is here with a look
at how Cornell changed rock music
Anthony good morning good morning just
before that show at the Fox Theatre in
Detroit last night Cornell tweeted out a
picture of the marquee he was in the
midst of a month-long tour with
Soundgarden the band he fronted which
along with Nirvana and Pearl Jam were
founding members of the Seattle grunge
sound
[Music]
Chris Cornell helped redefine the sound
of rock and roll in the late 80s and
early 90s
[Music]
emerging from the Seattle grunge scene
as the frontman of Soundgarden
the singer was known for his octave
smashing vocal range
his talent spilled across a number of
lineups over the years including the
supergroup
temple of the dog
[Music]
and a seven-year run with former members
of Rage Against the Machine in
Audioslave exactly it's exactly in the
worst last month he told me he was
working on a new Soundgarden album and
how far away is the new Soundgarden um
one of the things we did when we got
back together was decide to never put a
clock on what we do which I think has
been really helpful and it just always
being a positive experience and in the
studio that day he performed an acoustic
version of perhaps Soundgarden's
best-known song black hole son
chu
you
[Music]
she come
really extraordinary performance that
day this news is just as just stunned
everybody came out of nowhere 52 years
old he has three children in a statement
his family says they'll be working with
the medical examiner to figure out
exactly what happened no cause of death
at this point he was just here in this -
he was in the studio last month and
though that you would talk to him and
you get this news
yeah and seemed in very good shape when
he was here right a real stunner weight
loss thank you